Pergunta que chegou para mim, vitamina D
diária reduz o risco de desenvolver
doenças autoimunes? Eu acho que essa é
uma ótima oportunidade pra gente falar
sobre o papel fundamental da vitamina D
na prevenção e tratamento de várias
doenças autoimunes. Se você chegou até
aqui procurando saber se vitamina D
previne doenças autoimunes, eu vou ser
bem direto com você? A resposta é sim,
mas tem um problema enorme que eu
preciso te contar antes de você sair
correndo para comprar aquele frasco de
vitamina D na farmácia. Porque 97 em
cada 100 pessoas que tomam vitamina D
estão, na verdade piorando o problema
sem saber. Deixa te contar uma história.
Há pouco tempo recebi uma paciente que
veio me dizendo: "Doutor, tomo 5.000
unidades de vitamina D todo dia, tem 3
anos, mas os meus marcadores
inflamatórios só pioram. O que que tá
acontecendo?" Quando eu pedi os exames
dela, descobri algo que me deixou de
cabelo em pé. O cálcio dela estava se
depositando nas artérias, não nos ossos.
E sabe por quê? Ela estava tomando
vitamina D sozinha, sem os cofatores
essenciais. Era como se estivesse
jogando gasolina numa fogueira. Agora,
presta atenção, porque o que eu vou te
mostrar agora vai mudar completamente
sua visão sobre suplementação de
vitamina D. Em 2022 saiu um estudo
gigantesco chamado vital, que acompanhou
mais de 25.000 pessoas por 5 anos. E o
resultado foi impressionante. Quem tomou
2000 unidades de vitamina D diariamente
teve uma redução de 22% no risco de
desenvolver doenças autoimunes. 22%, meu
amigo. Isso inclui artrite, amatoide,
psoriase, doença de rashimoto, esclerose
múltipla. Mas aqui vem a parte que
ninguém te conta. O efeito só começou a
aparecer depois de 2, 3 anos. Não é
mágica instantânea. E tem mais uma
pegadinha nesse estudo. Eles usaram
apenas 2.000 unidades por dia. Na
prática clínica, a gente vê que muita
gente precisa de bem mais que isso.
Precisa de 5.000, 10.000, às vezes
20.000 por dia para alcançar os níveis
ideais no sangue. Por que que o
laboratório vai te dizer que 30 ng por
mililro tá bom? Mais estudos recentes
mostram que para prevenir autoimune de
verdade você precisa estar entre 60 e 80
nanog. Aí que mora o problema. Mas agora
vem a bomba que eu preciso de soltar. E
eu quero que você grave isso bem. Tomar
vitamina D sozinha sem os cofatores
corretos pode ser pior do que não tomar
nada. Eu sei que sou a radical, mas
deixa te explicar o mecanismo. Quando
você toma vitamina D, a D3, ela aumenta
a absorção de cálcio no intestino.
Beleza? tá aqui. Mas para que esse
cálcio vá para os lugares certos, ossos
e dentes, você precisa de duas coisas,
K2 e magnésio. Se não tem esses caras na
jogada, o cálcio vai se depositar onde
ele não devia, nas suas artérias, nos
seus rins, os seus tecidos moles. Existe
uma proteína chamada MGP Matrix GLA
Protein, que funciona como um porteiro.
Ela é que decide se o cálcio vai entrar
nos ossos ou se vai ficar entupindo as
suas artérias. Mas para essa proteína
funcionar, ela precisa ser ativada pela
vitamina K2. E tem um detalhe meio
sinistro nisso tudo. Quem toma vitamina
D aumenta a produção dessa proteína MGP.
Só que se você não tem K2 suficiente,
que é produzido pelas bactérias do
intestino, muitas vezes se você tiver
uma boa flora intestinal, essa proteína
fica inativa. E proteína MGP inativa
significa calsificação arterial
acelerada. O Rotterdam Study, um estudo
holandês que acompanhou mais de 4.000
pessoas por 10 anos, mostrou que quem
consumia pelo menos 32 microgamina K2
por dia teve 50% menos calcificação
arterial e 50% menos risco de doença
cardíaca. 50%.
E não foi com vitamina K1 que você
encontra em verduras verdes, foi com a
K2 que vem de alimentos fermentados e
produtos animais. A diferença é brutal.
E o magnésio, rapaz, sem magnésio você
nem consegue ativar a vitamina D. Tem
umas enzimas no fígado e nos rins que
convertem a vitamina D3 na forma ativa.
E essas enzimas são dependentes de
magnésio. É tipo querer ligar o carro
sem a chave. Pode ter gasolina, pode ter
motor bom, mas sem a chave não vai para
lugar nenhum. Estudos mostram que quem
tem magnésio baixo precisa de doses
muito maiores de vitamina D para atingir
os mesmos níveis sanguíneos. É um
desperdício danado. Então, qual que é o
protocolo que realmente funciona? Deixa
eu te dar um o ouro aqui. Vitamina D3
entre 5 a 10.000 unidades por dia,
dependendo do seu peso, dos seus níveis
atuais. Junto com isso, K2 na forma MK7,
que é a forma de longa duração, 200
microg por dia. E magnésio,
preferencialmente o glicinato, porque
tem melhor absorção, 400 mg por dia.
Essa é a trinca que funciona. Sem essa
combinação, você tá jogando dinheiro
fora e pior, pode estar criando um
problema no lugar de resolver. Agora,
timing importa. Vitamina D liposolúvel.
Então, tem que tomar com gordura. de
manhã, junto com o seu café da manhã,
que tem abacate, ovos, azeite de oliva.
O magnésio muita gente prefere tomar à
noite porque ajuda no relaxamento
muscular e no sono. Melhora o sono. A K2
pode ir junto com a vitamina D, sem
problema. Também é liposolúvel. É
simples quando você entende o mecanismo.
E olha só que dada interessante. Um
estudo finlandês de 2001 acompanhou mais
de 10.000 crianças e descobriu que
aquelas que receberam suplementação de
vitamina D desde cedo tiveram até cinco
vezes menos chance de desenvolver
diabetes tipo um mais tarde na vida.
cinco vezes. Isso mostra o poder da
vitamina D quando você pega o copõ de
inflamação, quando o timo, aquela
glândula que treina as células imunes,
ainda tá aprendendo a diferencial que é
o pseudo, que é invasor. Uma pesquisa de
2024 da McGill University do Canadá
mostrou que deficiência de vitamina D
faz o timo envelhecer mais rápido,
deixando o sistema imune vazado, como
eles chamam. Significa que células
imunes que deveriam ser eliminadas
escapam e começam a atacar o próprio
corpo. Agora tem um outro detalhe que
poucos médicos vão te contar. No estudo
vital, quando pararam de dar vitamina D
pro pessoal, o efeito protetor
desapareceu em menos de 2 anos. Isso te
diz uma coisa importante, não é
tratamento pontual, é estilo de vida.
Você não vai tomar vitamina D por 6
meses, parar e achar que tá protegido
para sempre. O corpo precisa de níveis
sustentados. Por isso que na abordagem
funcional a gente pensa em manutenção,
não em cura e abandono. E para quem já
tem alguma doença autoimune, aí os
benefícios podem ser ainda maiores.
Isudos mostram que pessoas que têm
esclerose múltipla, lupus, artrite
amatoide, quando aumentam os níveis de
vitamina D para faixa de 60 a 80 ng,
frequentemente vem redução os marcadores
inflamatórios. Não é cura milagrosa, mas
é uma ferramenta poderosa no arenal.
Alguns pesquisadores defendem de níveis
ainda mais altos até 80 a 100 ng, mas aí
você precisa de supervisão porque entra
numa zona onde o benefício adicional
pode não compensar o risco. Outro ponto
crucial, obesidade. Pessoas acima do
peso precisam de doses muito maiores de
vitamina D porque ela é lipossolúvel,
fica retida no tecido de poso, tecido
gorduroso. Um estudo no vital mostrou
que o efeito protetor da vitamina D
contra a autoimunidade foi mais forte em
pessoas com peso normal ou baixo do que
em pessoas obesas, provavelmente porque
o corpo consegue utilizar melhor
vitamina D quando ela não fica presa na
gordura corporal. Agora, deixa eu te
falar de uma controvérsia. Tem médico
que vai te dizer que vitamina K2 não
funciona porque saíram alguns estudos
recentes mostrando que suplementação com
K2 não reduz calsificação de válvula
ótica. É verdade, esses estudos existem,
mas quando você olha os detalhes,
descobre que eles usaram doses baixas
por períodos curtos em pessoas que já
tinham calcificação severa. É como
tentar apagar o incêndio com um copinho
de água e depois dizer que água não
apaga fogo. Os estudos populacionais de
longo prazo, como Rotterdam, continuam
mostrando o benefício claro. E aqui vai
uma verdade que dói. Você não vai
conseguir níveis adequados de K2 só com
alimentação. A menos que você coma NATO,
que é um alimento japonês fermentado de
soja todo dia, ou queijos fermentados
como gudá envelhecido. A alimentação
ocidental padrão é palpérma em K2, por
isso que a suplementação faz sentido.
Nossos avós conseguiam porque comiam
víceras, manteiga de animais criados no
pasto e muitos fermentados. Hoje em dia
a galera come peito de frango sem pele e
acho que tá fazendo certo. Deixa contar
mais um caso real. Tive um paciente com
marcadores de autoimune começando a
aparecer anticorpos antinucleares
borderline, ou seja, no limite, fadiga
crônica e articulações doendo. Nível de
vitamina D, 22 NГ. Coloquei num
protocolo completo 10.000 unidades de
vitamina D3, 200 micrg de K2, 400 mg de
magnésio. 6 meses depois, vitamina D foi
para 68 e os anticorpos que estavam
começando a subir voltaram pro normal.
As dores articulares sumiram, a energia
voltou e ele me disse: "Doutor, parece
que eu voltei a ter 30 anos, mas não foi
só a vitamina D, foi o protocolo
completo, porque sozinha aquela vitamina
D ia fazer ele absorver um monte de
cálcio e provavelmente ia danificar,
calcificar as artérias. Com os
cofatores, o corpo conseguiu usar a
vitamina D porque ela serve? Modular o
sistema imune, fortalecer os ossos,
reduzir inflamação. É a diferença entre
dar uma ferramenta e ensinar como usar
essa ferramenta. Tem um conceito
importante aqui que é a sinergia de
nutrientes. Na visão integrativa, a
gente não olha nutrientes de forma
isolada. Vitamina D trabalha com K2, que
trabalha com magnésio, que trabalha com
zinco, é uma orquestra. Se o violino não
tá desafinado, não adianta, o piano está
perfeito, o som fica ruim, seu corpo é
assim, precisa de todos os elementos
trabalhando juntos. E aqui vai outra
bomba. Muita gente suplementa cálcio
achando que vai fortalecer os ossos, mas
cálcio vitamina K2 pode ser prejudicial.
Estudos recentes mostram que
suplementação de cálcio isolado pode
aumentar risco cardiovascular justamente
por causa disso, calcificação arterial.
Então se você toma cálcio, mais razão
ainda para tomar K2, porque o problema
não é o cálcio em si, é para onde ele
vai.
Agora, uma reflexão. Por que isso não é
amplamente divulgado? Por que que o seu
médico provavelmente não vai te falar
sobre isso? Duas razões principais.
Primeira, formação médica tradicional
não aprofunda em bioquímica nutricional.
Médico aprende sobre deficiências
extremas, escorbuto, beriber,
raquitismo, mas não sobre otimização.
Segundo, não tem patente para vitaminas
naturais, não dá dinheiro grande paraa
indústria farmacêutica. Então, não tem
propaganda, não tem representante
batendo na porta do consultório,
oferecendo o jantar. para falar de
vitamina D. É assim que o jogo funciona.
Mas a evidência tá aí. O estudo vital
custou milhões de dólares, foi
financiado pelo governo americano,
acompanhou 25.000 pessoas, não é
pesquisinha de quintal. E os resultados
são claros. Vitamina D reduz risco de
autoimune. E os estudos sobre K2 e
calciusficação arterial também são
robustos. O problema é inércia do
sistema. Leva décadas para uma
informação científica às vezes chegar na
prática clínica do dia a dia quando não
é remédio patenteado. Então, se você
quer estar na frente, se você quer
prevenção de verdade, você precisa tomar
as rédias. Pede pro teu médico dosar uma
vitamina D. Se tiver abaixo de 60,
suplementa, mas suplementa direito. D3
com K2 e magnésio. E daosa de novo em 3
meses para ver se tá funcionando. Alguns
metabolisam vitamina D mais rápido,
outros mais devagar. Não é de bolo, é
individualização.
E quanto custa isso? Uma caixinha de
vitamina D3 com K2 mais magnésio para um
mês sai por menos que um jantar fora.
Estamos falando de R$ 100, R$ 150 no
máximo. É barato se você considerar o
custo de uma doença autoimune. Remédios
imunossupressores custam milhares de
dólares. Consultas especializadas,
exames fora a qualidade de vida que vai
pro ralo. Prevenção sempre mais barata
que tratamento. Agora deixa eu te dar
uma última informação importante. Se
você já toma alguma medicação
anticoagulante, tipo vafarina, você não
pode tomar vitamina K2 sem
acompanhamento médico, sem o seu médico
autorizar, porque K2 interfere no
mecanismo de ação dessas medicações.
Então, nesse caso, o médico precisa
ajustar as doses. Mas se você usa
anticoagulantes mais modernos, tipo
Rivaroxabana,
alguns estudos sugerem que a interação é
menor. De qualquer maneira,
transparência comomédica é fundamental.
E tem outro grupo que precisa de
atenção, gestantes. Vitamina D é super
importante na gestação, mas as doses
precisam ser ajustadas. Estudos mostram
que filhos de mães com boa vitamina D na
gravidez tem menos chance de desenvolver
autoimune mais tarde. Mas conversa com
teu obstetra antes de sair
experimentando por conta. O que eu quero
que você entenda é simples. Vitamina D
funciona contra doenças autoimunes. A se
aprovou, mas só funciona se você fizer
direito com os cofatores, com as doses
adequadas, com níveis otimizados, não
apenas suficientes, segundo o
laboratório. E com consistência não
adianta tomar 3 meses e parar. Então
aqui vai meu recado final para você. Se
você se preocupa com doença autoimune,
se tem histórico familiar, se já tá
sentindo sintomas estranhos, não fique
esperando a doença se instalar. Dosagem,
vitamina D é barata, tá disponível em
qualquer laboratório. Suplementação
também é acessível e o conhecimento tá
aqui. Agora você tem. O que falta é
ação. Pega esse conhecimento, aplica na
tua vida. daqui a seis meses você vai
olhar para trás e agradecer por ter
tomado essa decisão hoje.